the opportunities are endless and it's
really not like i did anything special
that can't be replicated
anyone can do this anyone can pick up on
trends and just try to put your own spin
to it
and make this happen because the thing
with youtube is
you can't really control if you get a
viral video or not that's
mostly up to the youtube algorithm but
the factors that you can control
are things like how much value are you
really providing
are you picking up on trendy things and
those are the factors you can control so
if you really focus on that
then eventually i'm convinced that
everyone is going to get that shot from
the youtube algorithm
welcome to the think marketing podcast
the number one podcast for growing and
scaling your business with online video
i'm heather torres and i'm sean cannell
and we're from think media and if this
is your first time listening
welcome this show is dedicated to
helping you learn how to get your
content noticed and the latest money
making strategies working right now
online so whether you want to grow your
youtube channel
or you want to maximize video across all
of social media
this podcast is for you well think
marketing podcast listener
i am fired up for today's episode
because i'm bringing to you
an entrepreneur who's just like you one
of the things i love about doing here
on the think marketing podcast is
bringing real life examples of people
who are using video to grow their
business
just like you i'm sure that you're
trying to get eyeballs on the things
that you've created and my interview
today with my friend erica kohlberg
is going to help inspire you to lean in
even more with video
and let me tell you a little bit about
erica so i can tee up this interview
that i did with her
erica is an attorney and personal
finance expert she's been featured in
u.s news and world report business
insider and the washington post she's
also the founder of plug-in law
which provides legal agreements for
online businesses and entrepreneurs i'll
tell you more about plug-in law after
this episode we talk a little bit about
it inside of the interview
but she's actually a graduate from
georgetown law and
she went to the university of notre dame
what i love about what erica has done
though is she actually has pivoted out
of corporate america she's gone
fully online and she's really figured
out in under eight months how to
capitalize on using
video just like you saw from this title
i think it's critical that you
understand
that video can help you go viral which
can help you grow
your business so i encourage you to lean
into this podcast episode grab your
notebook if you're taking notes
if you're out on a walk or you're
driving in your car i want you to pick
up on the subtle things that erica's
talking about
speaking directly to you business owners
she really is in this to help you grow
she's helping you learn the tips that
she's used
but she's also there just as someone
just like you
she just picked up a camera she was
completely nervous had no idea what to
do
and she just pressed record so lean in
today's podcast
with erica kohlberg well erica thank you
so much for
joining me on the think marketing
podcast how are you doing
thank you for having me heather i'm
great this is
so fun to be on this podcast i i think
your story to me is just so
inspiring and i can't wait to kind of
dig into the details of it and really
dive
into how you've grown your channel to
over three million views
in under a year's time and you had one
specific strategy that we
really came down to that really helped
blow up your channel and i want to get
into that but first
for everyone who's just listening can of
give us a little bit of a background as
to how you even got started on youtube
but even just a little bit before that
what even was your journey to youtube
sure that's a great question so i'm a
lawyer by background
and basically i practiced corporate law
at this
big law firm and towards the end of my
time there
i was really starting to get fed up with
the culture
but also i wanted to do something
different with my life and i had this
idea for
an online legal company that i wanted to
start and so i was really excited about
that but i also wanted to do something
that was completely unrelated to
law and just something out of my comfort
zone and something where i could feel
like
i was helping people because as a
corporate lawyer you're only helping
these big corporations you're helping
big corporations get richer
so i wanted to do something that was
non-legal
and also really would help people and
put myself out of my comfort zone so for
me the natural thing was to talk about
personal finance
and the reason i love personal finances
learning about personal finance and all
of these tips and tricks
led me to paying off 225 000
of student loans within two years and
that's what allowed me to quit my job to
start my own company so i'm really
grateful to the people who taught me
about it so i kind of wanted to
spread that knowledge and i thought
between a blog and a youtube channel a
blog is just very natural to me i love
writing i love being behind a computer
that's
what i'm used to but youtube was some
a completely foreign thing that i could
never
a year ago if you told me i would be on
youtube i wouldn't have believed you i
it's just so foreign to me but i was
like i need to
try to put myself out of my comfort zone
and do that so that's how the youtube
channel started and
my goal really wasn't to become big on
youtube
my goal was to just try to help even
like five viewers
and stay consistent so from the
beginning i said i'm going to do it for
one year
one video every single week 52 videos
and then see how i like it see what
happens from there wow there's so much i
want to unpack there i love that you
started out of passion
for the project i love that you paid off
your debt so that you could start this i
think there's so many pieces
um that i want to help creators with and
and those two are
are such big ones but i want to go back
to you said a year ago
you would not have been the person to do
a youtube channel so
uh let's go back to those first five
ten videos that you created one how did
it finally feel
to start putting this information out
into the world
it's hard i i think i had a lot of
internal fears but then from the
external side i also had
other lawyers telling me like you can't
be on youtube you're going to ruin your
professional image
and i had other lawyers telling me it
was such a bad idea
but i think i'm kind of rebellious so
that almost motivated me more
to like just to do it and
so it was it was tough like the first
video
i was so uncomfortable i was sweating i
forgot to plug in my mic
like all the beginner mistakes that you
make even though
i had prepared like i had watched think
media videos i had watched all of these
videos to like learn about the game of
youtube
and i was still utterly unprepared and
but you just have to start that's what
i've learned is you really have to start
you can't be a perfectionist about
youtube because the only way you're
going to learn and grow is by actually
doing it
not by watching videos about how to do
it so oh
that is so key i that that resonates
with me so much because
i have the same fears trying to get on
video i'm like three if
10 years ago if you would have told me
this would be my career that's no way
that would have happened
now you just touched on it a little bit
and i want to maybe just have you speak
into the listener right now who
has a professional career that may not
be
technically suited for youtube in other
people's eyes
um walk me through how you overcame that
because we do have a lot of business
owners who have traditional businesses
like real estate agents and plumbers and
electricians and
you know um uh copywriters and people
who don't technically do
youtube right because you're not a
youtuber you're a business owner
using youtube to grow a business so walk
me through what that felt like and how
you overcame
the idea of actually having to step
out of that right that professional
non-traditional youtube role and come
into this space yeah that's a really
good question i think
so the thing about leaving your comfort
zone
is the first step out of your comfort
zone is the hardest it just it feels so
tremendous like a leap almost but then
every step afterwards gets much easier
so
for me like the act of recording and
posting the first video
was absolutely the hardest but then
every video after that like it's already
out there in the public
people who are gonna judge already
judged it's fine like it's out there
and then i think also now that i'm a
business owner an online business owner
on top of being on youtube on top of
being a lawyer i really
see the potential for any business owner
to be on youtube
because it's not about subscribers it's
about views and when you're a business
owner on youtube
you're attracting highly qualified leads
because
they're searching for a specific thing
that they're looking for for me
i'm selling on my legal company website
one of the things we sell is privacy
policy so i'm about to launch a separate
business youtube channel where all i
talk about is the legal stuff
so if someone's searching for a privacy
policy hopefully that
the idea is my my privacy policy video
is going to come up top
and that's going to be a very qualified
lead for business so i think you have to
get
over the fear as a business owner of
putting yourself out on camera
realize you're not going to be great at
the beginning but realize how
instrumental it is for your business
there this is only going in one
direction and the thing about
putting yourself on camera versus a
business having a traditional blog
is there's the know like and trust
factor when people see
you in person they automatically are
going to connect with you far more than
they ever will through
a a piece that you've written oh man
oh i just i'm over here just shaking my
head if you're not watching the video
and you're just listening to the podcast
right now i'm over here just
giddy by the things that you're saying
erica because that is so
real it's the know like and trust factor
and the qualified lead
that you technically get for free right
like you put this video out there i mean
yeah it's work and you may have to
you know um you may have a team around
you or whatever that looks like but
literally this is like free
advertisement to the exact thing that
your target audience wants i cannot wait
to geek out
um but looking at your channel erica
you've been on
youtube now for less than a year you
just said you know it really isn't about
the subscribers which i completely agree
with and the views is what really
matters you're over
already three million views can we just
clap it up and just be so excited for
that how awesome
is that walk me through how did you do
it how did you get to three million
views there was a main strategy that you
had
after you got a couple videos out that
you were like aha this is the thing
walk me through that journey sure so
i think so on youtube just as background
there's evergreen content and then
there's trendy content really
and for my channel i was doing personal
finance i only wanted to do evergreen
content i wanted to do things that you
know how to save money
that it wouldn't matter if you watch it
now or a year from now so i was very
hesitant to
jump onto trends and then
the first stimulus check was announced
and
i started to see that tons of people
were searching for
stimulus content related to the next
stimulus check
and then another thing i noticed was so
as a
small youtuber one of the biggest best
techniques i have for growing when
you're
at zero subscribers is to comment on
other channels within your niche
so because of that i was following
probably
80 to 90 personal finance channels
within my niche
so it's very very easy for me to pick up
on trends because
i'm following 90 channels so i started
to see that other channels were doing it
and then i thought that maybe from a
legal perspective
i could actually read the bill and
provide really valuable information that
maybe not everyone can provide because
not everyone has the time to read a 100
page bill
to tell you what a stimulus check is and
what the rules are behind it
so i decided to jump onto that trendy
topic
and sure enough i created i think i was
i had done 25 videos
so i'd done 25 weeks of youtube one
video per week
and then i released two stimulus videos
that day that tuesday
and prior to that probably the highest
amount of views i'd gotten was around
100 on the first day that was like 100
would be a big deal for me
and that day that i released the
stimulus check it was
unbelievable like i thought my metrics
were broken i was seeing it just go
up and up and i think in the first day
it was like 20 000 views
which was crazy it was my very first
video i put out on a trendy topic on
stimulus checks and it just blew up so
after that i realized
there's probably a need here people
enjoyed that content so let me
just go ahead and do that so i broke my
rule of only doing one video a week and
so i released two or three that week and
then
i've just kept going since then
wow i love how you spotted the trend
and you we we say here at uh think
marketing and think media
different is better than better and you
thought what's the spin i could put on
it right like you said you were
following all these other
um financial youtube channels and they
were talking about it but you're like
what is the
thing i can do that made it different
and because you are
a lawyer because you have that
background you understand that you are
able to bring a different perspective
and i think
one thing you can learn here at think
marketing is exactly what erica just
said you know she
was doing two really critical things she
was
involved in the niche that she wants to
grow in and two she spotted the trend
and decided that she was gonna break the
rules and
actually make the content that the
viewer wanted
right when we take ourselves out of our
own self and we think about what is the
viewer need right now
erica walk me through how that has grown
your channel
how that has grown your business what
does that look like because
you doubled down you didn't just make
one video a week like you said you
doubled down and started making a
ton of videos on this i think i counted
like 40
videos since that first one i'm thinking
how do you even have the time for that
but walk me through what is this done
for your credibility what is this done
for your business
tell me a little bit about that
yeah it's really i mean it's a game
changer going from
i think i went from 2 000 subscribers
to 50 000 within 30 days and
at that point when i had my first viral
or semi
viral for my standards viral uh stimulus
video
i was not even monetized i had 2 000
hours of watch time at that point
and if you know that you need 4 000
hours to be monetized so
i wasn't even close my i i treat this
kind of like a business
so my i was estimating that i would mon
get monetized by june so because of that
first one i ended up getting monetized
end of april obviously from a financial
perspective i think within those 30 days
after getting monetized i made 20 000
which is unheard of i was making zero
before that
and it's also been great for my
online business plug-in law too because
it's brought a lot more attention to it
and more people know that i'm a lawyer
because
every stimulus video starts with lawyer
explains
so i make it very obvious and i think
it's just it's been an absolute game
changer
obviously having think media reach out
to me i had
business insider do an article on me the
opportunities are endless and it's
really not like i did anything special
that can't be replicated
anyone can do this anyone can pick up on
trends and just try to put your own spin
to it and
make this happen because the thing with
youtube is you can't really control
if you get a viral video or not that's
mostly up to the youtube algorithm
but the factors that you can control are
things like how much value are you
really providing
um are you picking up on trendy things
and those are the factors you can
control so if you really focus on that
then eventually i'm convinced that
everyone is going to get that shot from
the youtube algorithm
i could not agree more we always say
it's about the base hits
that will turn into the home runs right
like it really is you just have to keep
putting the content out there
and one thing i love about the content
you're putting out is um you say at the
beginning
you know this channel is is a financial
channel i'm a lawyer and i'm talking
about this today like you're not
putting yourself in a box where this
channel will only be about a stimulus
check right you're just saying
this is the trend in the industry that
i'm in and i'm also talking about it and
i love that you
still give yourself that gap that you
could also talk about apps so you can
talk about financial
um you know financial uh ways that
people can handle their money all these
different things still but right now
you're just choosing to ride
the trend i think that's so critical
erica walk me through as a business
owner what does your team
look like are you doing all this on your
own have you outsourced it because i
know a lot of business owners come into
youtube
trying to be the only person on the team
what does your team
look like as you have exploded your
channel
yeah that's great so my biggest tip for
a business owner
the biggest excuse that business manager
owners have not to start youtube
is time they're like i can't find time
well the thing is if you outsource
every component that you can actually
outsource youtube shouldn't take you
that long and the rewards can just be
exponential so it's
certainly worth the time that you put
into it so actually i'm probably unique
from the very beginning
i saw youtube as an investment not
necessarily for this personal finance
channel but because i knew i was going
to create this
second legal channel so i saw it as an
investment for
my business and so i outsourced
everything from
video one really uh so video editing i
have a great editor that does all of my
editing
uh thumbnails i have someone that does
thumbnails because
as a business owner if i did learn how
to edit so i
watched youtube videos and learned how
to do adobe premiere pro
but first of all i spent like 40 hours
doing that staying up
late at night and then i realized when i
first
started editing editing my videos the
video was taking me actually like eight
hours to edit
and that's just not efficient when
you're trying to run a business so
i outsource that from the beginning and
highly recommend doing that because
it'll just take a load off your plate
and the
more you make the process of youtube
simple and
stop trying to control every single
aspect of it the more likely you are to
continue with it because you're going to
have more time freed up
due to outsourcing yeah and i know you
spend a lot of time actually preparing
for your videos right so rather than
you being the person that is learning
the editing and making the thumbnails
and tweaking all the things
you're spending a good portion of your
time actually just preparing to make
valuable content can you walk me through
why that is so important and why you
think that's really made you
grow on youtube sure so
i remember when i was just about to
start youtube and was watching all of
these videos on think media
and these other outlets one of the
things that you hear a lot of creators
say
is the number one most important thing
is to provide valuable content
and really make it that your audience
like
loves every piece of the information
you're providing and it finds it very
unique and valuable
and when you're first starting out you
don't really understand what that means
i was like that's so fluffy like i need
concrete advice like how do i do it
that's not helpful
but unfortunately like now that i'm on
the other side and have this channel
that's the best advice i can give is put
the most
time into preparing researching
scripting or at least bullet pointing
second most time should go into
uh filming and that shouldn't take that
long and then
least is least priority is the editing
really because i don't think
editing is really the game changer i
think what's the game changer is
how valuable the content is and that
comes from the phase where you're
researching and preparing so for me
again because i knew my differentiating
factor for the stimulus checks was that
i could actually
read the bills and digest them and then
put them into
video format and summarize a hundred
pages into a two minute video
that's where the bulk of my time goes so
for a hundred page bill i mean it takes
me like 10
15 hours to read and prepare just to
create a five-minute video and people
don't see all of the work that goes into
the back end
but i think they appreciate it and i
think that's why
i was able to be successful
i guess in this in this space yeah and
you're just getting started isn't that
amazing to think like you're just
getting started you figured out
what works for you and how you can make
that grow and i
i love that you're also you have a heart
for creators you have a heart for this
industry
in people understanding um the legal
side or even just understanding
what they need to do to protect
themselves tell me just a little bit
about the business that you're in in the
next youtube channel that you're going
to be starting
sure so the business is called plug-in
law
and basically the reason i wanted to
start it is because
again i was this corporate lawyer
highest-paid corporate lawyer one of the
biggest law firms
and i really felt like i was only
helping these corporations it wasn't
satisfying it the money only matters to
a certain point right
eventually you have to do something in
your life that has an impact and i saw
this huge gap in the legal industry
where online creators for instance if
they want
legal help they have two choices really
the first is to get stuff for free
online so let's say they need a privacy
policy
for their website they can find one for
free online unfortunately they're not
very great they don't really protect you
or they can hire a lawyer which is too
expensive for
everyone starting out basically and
there was this huge middle gap
so i wanted to create a business where i
could use
templates so for example the privacy
policy has a template where
i walk you through the sections that you
need to fill out and walk you through
why it's important
and use video to do that so you're
actually being
handheld by an attorney but it doesn't
but you're not paying attorney prices
it's
probably less than 10 of what you'd
actually pay for an attorney
so i saw that gap but i wanted to use
video as the medium
to make legal more accessible because i
think also a lot of lawyers
operate based on fear they like to scare
you and say like
you're gonna get sued as a small
business owner if you don't have these
documents in place
i don't like that i think it's important
yes but i'm never going to scare you
into sale
my goal is to really be like this
anti-lawyer like i don't i don't want
these lawyers taking three thousand
dollars from you at the beginning of
your business
where when it's so critical to invest
that money elsewhere
so i really want to make this product
where you're getting top
quality legal documents for your
business but you're not paying an arm
and a leg for it so that's how
plug and loss started and that's my
mission with that is really to help
others who are just like me like now i'm
an online creator
i'm an online business owner so i really
understand the needs
of online creators and online business
owners too so
that's really my goal with plug-in law
wow
i i've already signed up i'm like i'm in
you've sold me i'm like totally there i
cannot wait for all the creators
listening on the think marketing podcast
uh to get connected with you because i
think it's really important that we
understand
as we move into this space of online
business how can we
we can be protected and the laws that
are around it so i just
i'm so grateful that you've stepped into
that zone to help creators like us
be able to do that erica where can
people connect with you
if they want to go deeper and they want
to follow along on your journey
yeah the best place is for
my personal brand ericacoberg.com and
then for my legal website it's
pluganlaw.com
awesome so we'll make sure that that is
linked in the youtube description below
as well as if you're listening right now
on itunes or spotify it'll be in the
description so you can click on that
head over
and connect with erica well erica thank
you so much for being on today i love to
always ask the guest
uh the last question which is if you
could give yourself advice
when you first got started knowing what
you know now
what would you tell yourself that's
really good probably just don't let fear
stop you don't let yourself stop you
from
achieving what you could possibly
achieve on youtube because there are too
many people out there who
have dreamt of starting a channel but
never actually start because
they lit all these things like oh what
are people gonna say like am i gonna be
horrible are people gonna write me
comments they let those things really
impact them and prevent them from
starting
so my biggest thing is just to start the
hardest part of youtube
is starting and the second hardest part
is consistency and both of those are in
your control so
well i hope that video from erica just
inspired you to go
all in on video can you believe she's
accomplished that in just
eight months i mean it's amazing to see
what you can do
and how she's actually been able to
reach some financial goals
just off of her youtube channel and if
you want any information
about her products that she has at
plug-in law you can get that down
in the description box below if you are
watching on youtube and if you're
listening on the podcast we'll make sure
to make that link available to you in
the show notes
because i want to make sure you can go
over and get any assistance you need
from erica
for any online services uh related to
that so
here's the thing this episode is brought
to you by grow with video live did you
know
our online conference is right around
the corner yeah
you can get access for just 97
that's the ticket to get you in for this
virtual event
and i am so excited for what is being
created behind the scenes we are working
non-stop to make this one of the best
online experiences you will ever have we
are not only bringing the strategy
we're going to be bringing the mindset
as well as the community this isn't just
another webinar this isn't just another
facebook group
this is the ultimate online conference
and i cannot wait
to meet you there this september so make
sure you grab your tickets
you can go to growwithvideolive.com or
down in the description box or in the
show notes you can get directly over
there to get your ticket for as low as
97
to hear speakers like myself sean
cannell chalene johnson the think media
team pete vargas
we have vanessa lau we have uh katherine
manning from the content bug we have so
many great creators
who are going to be telling you how they
did it and giving you not just the
strategy
but the mindset behind winning on
youtube
along with youtube we're bringing you
other experts in all different fields
because we really believe that
dominating with video
dominating with video is so critical and
understanding how you do that across all
platforms like facebook and tick tock
and
linkedin and instagram is so critical
to your growth this year and so we're
bringing all that to you
at growth video live in september make
sure you pick up your tickets
for that conference and now it's time to
read
our review of the day did you know we do
this here at the think marketing podcast
you can go over to
itunes you can rate and review this
podcast and you might hear
your review read on the show so today's
comes from
susie j susie j said i was looking for a
marketing podcast to listen to
when i was walking the dog and i came
upon this one honestly i'm blown away by
the quality of the content
once i have listened to them all i'm
going to go back and listen to them
again
that's how good they are sean there was
one podcast where you said something
like whenever you're listening to this
podcast if you're out walking the dog
lean down lean down and give him a pat i
totally did it
when you said if you're going through
hell keep going i almost
cried yes yes yes again i could go on
and on but really i just want to thank
you for opening my eyes to a whole new
world and convincing me that yes i can
totally do this
i.e start my own business suze j
i am so excited for you to get started
on your business thank you so much for
listening to the think marketing podcast
and for leaving that review if you'd
like to be featured here on the podcast
you can go over to itunes right now you
can rate review and subscribe to the
podcast
and that shows us and itunes that you'll
like it
thank you so much again for listening to
the podcast it's time to take action
so what's your next video idea when are
you getting it recorded and
are you coming to grow with video live
make sure you get your tickets today at
growthvideolive.com and i'll see you in
the next episode
[Music]
you